the Joe Rogan experience what other
animals are you we were you hunting when
you up there anything unusual for big
animals the only the only thing around
is moose you said I shot one one grizzly
I shot one grizzly that was becoming a
problem that night it I I had a moose in
the camp my wife and the little baby
were there it's time to my and my
daughter was only three years old and my
son was you know just months old and
this moose was hanging there I just
killed it a week or so before and a
grizzly was coming around that night
trying to get that moose meat and I
chased it away a few times and he kept
coming back and you know eventually I
shot right over the bear trying to scare
it off sometimes that'll work if just
chasing them off doesn't work and but it
still he was walking toward me at 16
yards when I shot it Oh God
sixteen yards they could run sixteen
yards so fast yeah he was just walking
he wasn't thank God he wasn't running
yeah he wasn't trying to get me but he
was I just couldn't have that bear
hanging out there trying to get that
moose that I had there in the camp yeah
so you shot him and ate him yeah what
was that like oh the fat was
unbelievably good man the meat for me
bear meat like I said is not my first
choice I liked it but I'd only have a
desire to eat it once every four or five
days you know it's not like something I
wanted to eat pounds of every day the
way I can even caribou and moose it's
just different the fat was unbelievable
it's stunk terrible like I took all the
the fat out of the the internal
abdominal fat and all that stuff too and
boy did it smell bad just like bear guts
you know it just stunk
and I remember Sylvia saying you're
gonna eat that stuff and I was like I
don't know try it
so I rendered it and you know just
heated it up until it liquefied mm-hmm
and when that cooled back down no bad
flavor at all it was like almost
tasteless isn't the mildest fat you've
ever had really yeah that cured the the
bad bad smell
and I get past that though not a lot and
it's not it different it's bare fats
real soft it's it's real soft at room
temperature it's not like you know sheep
fats hard moose fat caribou fat is
slightly softer maybe than sheep fat but
it's still hard fat bear fat is soft and
creamy and so it was nice variety that
winter to have all that bear fat it was
really nice variety but I learned
something from that just a practical
thing that for some reason I don't
understand the chemistry behind it if
you got some fat that tasted funny if
you heat it up really hot and cool it
back down it'll take that away how'd it
happen with moose fat ones it was
getting old so it was getting a little
rancid and I tried it I heated it up
until it got just about to the smoking
point cooled it back down and it tasted
way better really yeah what do you think
is doing that I don't know I never
looked into it mm-hmm I think that would
be something you'd want to look into not
really just a little practical Boy Scout
trick once you know you know that's it
you don't need another magic behind it
so so you take what did you do with the
bear hide turned it into a blanket still
still have that hide
Wow it's a beautiful bear it really was
yeah how big was it I think was just
over 6 feet it wasn't huge because the
Bears up there don't get is big I mean
they don't have salmon up where I am
away by mountains but it was a real
light color bear there's a picture of
that one you might pull up yeah that's
it there's another picture with right
after I shot it on the beach there but
in the in the photos right on the first
page there whatever they're called those
ones that you can keep on this Facebook
oh you're just because the Facebook page
I can't zoomin in for some time so that
bear was super light-colored all its
claws are white
they're all white yeah this is beautiful
hide really and you keep the claws on
the hide when you make the blanket yeah
I just it was the only bear I ever dealt
with I skinned it all out like taxidermy
you know I left all the claws and the
lips and the eyelids and everything and
it took a long time and it--and it
myself it was a big project I built a
big stretcher had it all now what do you
use to tan it I used the same thing I
used on wolf or Wolverine which is like
diluted battery acid basically really
yeah what's the old way these do these
these brains right um yeah there's you
can't an with brains I hear but I never
got into that somebody showed me this
battery acid tanning system way back
when I when I first went up there and
started trapping and it worked really
well for me so I stuck to that how does
that work it's been a long time since I
did it but you just dilute the battery
acid is very diluted and I forgot the
exact proportions cuz it's been been a
while but it's very very diluted and
then you had a lot of salt also and you
want to get the proportions right so you
want to look into before you try it but
that's all that's in it the solution is
just battery acid water and salt and sea
in the rot battery acid up there just
yeah you don't it's so concentrated it's
like a little little package I flew it
out there like 1 times enough for 5
years or something you flew it out there
just for tanning yeah Wow yeah and that
system then you'll the other thing you
need is baking soda
you have to neutralize it you have to
get the pH back to neutral after you're
done tanning it here it is seven gallons
of water 2 to 2 pounds of brain wait
wait that's not the what I used 16 cups
of plain or pickling salt salts good ok
this is but there's a battery acid
three and a half cups battery acid from
auto parts store two boxes baking soda
yeah yeah that's pretty much it except
you can skip the bran flakes
what about foot oil what the [ __ ] is
foot oil neat's foot oil you never use
that stuff oh yeah that's
well you got to soften the hide
afterward you got to put the oil back
into it is that what foot oil is yeah
neat's foot oil where people's feet now
what do they make that from sheep feet
or something oh really I can't remember
no I don't know it's something they call
it neat's foot oil but it's just a oil
that you used to preserve leather oh you
put it on your baseball glove
neat's-foot is supposed to be one word
at least when i just googled it Oh neat
lol rendered from purified shin bones
and feet of cattle okay
how weird
[Applause]